no I I don't agree I people have been
attacking Alan Greenspan pretty
vigorously in the press lately and
laying the blame for the credit crisis
at his feet so what I think about that
is that is two things one is that in the
1990s Alan Greenspan could do no wrong
he was hailed as the maestro Bob
Woodward wrote a book called the maestro
and Bob Woodward said you know at the
end of The Wizard of Oz when the man
comes out behind the from behind the
curtain when the wizard shows his face
we feel a little bit underwhelmed but
with alan greenspan we always feel safe
or something like that i think they gave
him too much credit for monetary
policies when times were good because
when times are good things when the
economy is strong monetary policy is
really sort of boring but what alan
greenspan didn't realize was he just got
out of the way and let productivity
drive the economy and but we're the real
test of a central banker it comes is
when the usual rule books don't apply
when you're not just making monetary
policy for for ordinary times but when
you're subject to some fundamental
strains on the financial system and
Greenspan faced several such incidents
the first was October of 1987 when the
stock market collapsed another was the
asian financial crisis in the 1990s the
russian bond defaults in the 1990s there
was the collapse of long-term capital
management in the 1990s there was 911
and in all of those cases alan greenspan
understood what the what the role of the
central bank was was to provide enough
liquidity and keep the financial system
functioning and because he knew enough
because he did that in those instances
he came out of those crises with his
reputation enhanced and and that was his
real genius was to know what to do when
the system was was in a severe crisis
and and for all those reasons the the
shocks that were felt then didn't become
the new normal so the charge against him
is in lately has been that he kept
interest rates too low for too long but
when he left office there wasn't a lot
of inflation so there's a real question
about what you mean by interest rates
being too low for too long it was not
the case that he caused the housing
bubble you know it does having interest
rates low doesn't mean you have to make
unwise loans nor nor did he encourage
people to assume that prices could only
go up and up so I think he's a
convenient scapegoat